hollywood is the big propaganda tool
and hollywood is forcing one of its
stars
to bend the knee right now to america's
foremost enemy
john cena am i pronouncing that
correctly
if he were italian it would be
pronounced chaina but i don't know i
don't i don't know that i've ever seen a
movie that he's in but i guess he's in
the fast and the furious movies
he's in a lot of he's been big trouble
ho ho ho
boy you know there's always some
hollywood scandal what was it divorce
was it sexual harassment drugs
was he getting frisky with underage but
no no that's not the problem that the
scandal is
he acknowledged that taiwan is a country
john cena committed the egregious sin
of admitting that taiwan the country of
taiwan is a country
and china doesn't like that because
china wants to conquer taiwan
so so john cena issued an apology
a groveling apology to the chinese
communists
in mandarin on video take a listen i'll
translate
hello i'm john cena hey china i have to
say right now in fast and furious
nine i have many many interviews
in one of them
i made a mistake did you know what's the
mistake everyone asked me
if i can use chinese
[Music]
people at fast and furious nine i guess
as mandarin's not as good as one would
imagine
gave me lots of interview information
i uh i made a mistake
i have to say right now it's so so so so
so so so
important i love and respect china and
chinese people
i i love i'm so so sorry for my mistakes
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm very sorry you
have to understand
i love and respect china and chinese
people
i'm sorry this is like a hostage video
this is like one of those
coerced confessions in north korea i'm
sorry i'm he's crying
why did he by the way you'll notice he
doesn't acknowledge the mistake
we all know what the alleged mistake is
he said that china's or that taiwan
rather is a country
and not just a part of china he doesn't
quite acknowledge it
he knows that's going a little far to
just deny the existence of a sovereign
country
he says i'm so so i'm sorry please
please i'm sorry
no why
because if china decides
that they don't want fast and furious
nine playing in its borders
then the hollywood studios are gonna
lose billions and billions of dollars
the fast and furious movies have
consistently grossed
more money in china than any other
country including the united states
the audience for fast and furious is not
americans and you think it's an american
movie it's not it's a chinese movie
yeah it's with our actors and our
studios and our cultural institutions
and
and it's made in our country but it's
not really for
us it's for china because
he who pays the piper calls the tune
this in so many ways is what donald
trump woke us all
up to in 2016. he said there are elites
in this country who have sold out your
country to foreign powers to the highest
bidder
we now you sure i guess in class some
classrooms we have to have the american
flag but we're gonna have other flags
too blm
which right the blm is sort of the
anti-american flag it says that america
is a horrible racist evil bigoted
country
so you got the american flag then you
got the blm flag they cancel each other
out
and then you've got the pride flag the
deadliest of the seven deadly sins pride
goeth before destruction no haughty
spirit before a fall you gotta salute
that one too
totally drowning out that national
identity which people don't really
like very much anymore and now you've
got hollywood stars
groveling so pathetic
so pitiful the guy just we were talking
a lot about castration yesterday on the
show
we were talking a lot about similes
today on this show well he
metaphorically if not literally
castrated himself before xi jinping here
i'm sorry i'm so
so sorry you notice though that china
doesn't do this stuff
do you ever see chinese stars
well you don't really see a lot of
chinese stores anyway it's not like
china
as a thriving film industry do you ever
see chinese
tech moguls but well there aren't really
chinese tech moguls they just steal our
property right they just steal our
intellectual property
do you ever see any chinese
representatives groveling
begging the united states for
forgiveness no because they don't need
to
because we and by we i mean our elected
officials
and our appointed officials have put
ourselves in a very very weak position
what china does is they limit the number
of movies
foreign movies that can play
domestically even and that's so weird
because
you know foreign movies if you're in
china that just means hollywood
hollywood
is the movie-making capital of the world
and they're the best movies the biggest
the most expensive the most popular and
yet china limits
the number that can play domestically
why i'm sure
gdp would increase if they allowed more
of those movies to come in
the total free market wouldn't that be
wouldn't that be so great that that just
says that we have to let all the movies
in
but china says no because we're going to
protect our culture
we're going to protect our political
order and that's going to mean we limit
the
amount of american things that come into
this country our stupid
elites in this country won't do that
they'll say oh no it's great nothing
could be
better for america than flooding it with
chinese investment and cheap chinese
goods
many of which were produced after china
stole our intellectual property
nothing could be better for america than
flooding the country with
cheap labor from south of the border
effectively
canceling out our immigration system and
our immigration rules nothing could be
better
for america that's our strength isn't it
no you see the country falling apart all
around us
certainly that's none china doesn't do
it i was one of my favorite lines from
trump
when trump said yeah we're gonna we're
gonna institute some tariffs if these
other countries
don't start trading more fairly with us
and you had
the leftists who opposed trump and you
had the squishy
republican types all screaming like a
chicken with their head cut off
you can't possibly institute tariffs
tariffs are awful for the country
there's no good argument for tariffs
ever
and trump looked at them and said if
tariffs are just
uniformly terrible how come every other
country has them
if tariffs are so bad we know for sure
tariffs is so bad all the time
why do all the other countries have
tariffs but we're not allowed to
you're telling me all those other
countries are just totally wrong but
we're right
uh i'm not so sure and then what did he
do he institutes the tariffs and he gets
what he wants out of the trade deals
stop oh man that was close
ring the bell subscribe like so that you
will get notifications and
beyond that sure it's good to get the
notifications on youtube but you got to
head on over to apple podcasts
google play spotify myspace live journal
i don't know
all those podcast apps where you can get
the audio version
there have been some shenanigans
recently with the big tech companies
head on over there subscribe please
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you